ses 44 ans j'en ai posé 38 sachant que
comme un homme a commencé ses longs
tournée s'est tourné sur les antilles
c'est ferran 79 et j'ai intégré le
groupe
trois ans plus tard donc c'est pas rien
donc joyeux anniversaire au magnum je
vais les anniversaires ou musiciens et
tu sais quoi
sur cette lancée je voudrais quand même
saluer la mémoire de tous ces musiciens
qui ont oeuvré vont maintenant hommes
qui ont poussé la charrue de manière ce
que magnum tus fêté aujourd'hui ses 44
ans séparent c'est très important je
vais avoir une pensée pour ceux qui ont
travaillé avec nous et puis qui ne sont
partis vers l'opéra qui ont ils sont
partis bien bien avant non je pense à
michel moïse qui est un qui est un
bassiste du groupe magnum ouaga
albergoni laporte jean claude polony
qu'olivier charles fortunei dernièrement
frankie muniz a qui a quand même
travaillé si longtemps avec le roumain
en berne
ceux qui sont là et qui sont encore là
et qui ont oeuvré pour le magnum band
qui est comme je dis qu'ils avouent
qu'ils ont poussé la star oui je pense à
ernst gabriel
je pense à jean robert narcisse pour qui
tu as lu ma tasse le cas quand on verse
en dollars pour l'année games master
chéri est sous le feu de vives eaux
mondésir camille armand un raid et jean
louis pommier jamais eu peur car lille
et françois david lacombe roulant camo
félix étienne christophe lecteurs max
est un jeu mass accès des deux frères si
jude un mario tinto mitchell des salines
fait des glaces fargeas ça fait du beau
monde et je ne saurais passer
répondre à des questions pour ne pas
saluer ces gens là parce que ils ont
fait leur part du boulot
d'accord donc voilà et comme tu veux
demande quand on chante maintenant belle
créole haïtien ce qu'on n'oublie pas ses
glaces et non pas du tout ce serait
malvenu je suis menti nikkei je chante
dans un groupe haïtien
ça a ses bons côtés et ça à ses côtés
dérangeant peut-être penser à thème pour
d'autres aspects du métier
malheureusement mais écoute non je reste
martiniquais qui sont dans un groupe
comme le magnum belle et je pense que
n'importe qui dans le pays que ce soit
une augmentation moyenne si on avait
cette opportunité on l'aurait saisie et
voilà donc mon jeu c'est me transformer
un chanteur haïtien chante en créole
haïtien quand ils le quand il le faut et
puis quand tu te sens tu es un réel non
mon pays je
martinique je le fais et je pense que ça
c'est un atout c'est un plus je le vois
ici
donc non ça ne me gêne pas je suis
quelqu'un de la caraïbe heureusement si
je pourrais parler tous les créoles ou
chanter tout l'école ou faire des
expériences dans toute la caraïbe ou
pourquoi pas avec les mairies et voilà
c'est hubert aliciens dominicaine vers
mike and gas à savoir c'est que je pense
que c'est une expérience